Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Si je vous dis.
Bataille d'Alésia.
Accord au pluriel des mots se terminant en "ou"
Poser une division.
Évidemment, ça vous parle,
mais quand il s'agit
d'entrer dans le détail, ça coince un peu.
Ce sont pourtant des savoirs
que nous avons acquis en sixième.
Alors aujourd'hui, on va faire un petit bon dans le passé.
Retour au collège en classe de sixième
pour revoir ces savoirs fondamentaux.
C'est l'heure, je me dépêche.
Jamy au tableau !
bijou, caillou, chou,
genou, hibou, joujou et pou !
Ça vous rappelle quelque chose ?
Ces sept mots en "ou" sont des exceptions.
Au pluriel, ils ne prennent pas un "s",
comme les autres mots en "ou",
mais un "x".
Je sais, le français est une langue
compliquée, pleine d'exceptions.
Qui nous pourrissent un peu la vie.
À croire que c'est fait exprès pour qu'on a de mauvaises notes en dictée.
Pas du tout, ça s'explique.
Revenons à nos mots en "ou".
Pour les mémoriser, mon prof de français, le vôtre aussi sans doute,
nous avait soufflé
un petit truc assez pratique.
Une petite phrase,
vous l'avez peut-être encore en mémoire.
Ça faisait :
"Viens mon chou,
mon bijou sur mes genoux.
Prends ce caillou pour joujou et jette-le sur ce hibou plein de poux."
La leçon n'allait pas plus loin.
On nous expliquait rarement pourquoi
ces mots prenaient un "x" au pluriel.
Mais bon, vous me connaissez un peu,
je suis d'un naturel curieux.
Alors j'ai posé la question à mon prof.
Et comme c'était une super prof,
elle nous a donné la réponse.
Il se trouve qu'à l'origine, chou, hibou,
caillou et les autres prenaient un "s" au pluriel
comme tous les autres mots
en "ou"
C'est au Moyen Âge que ça change.
À cette époque, l'imprimerie n'existe
pas encore.
Ce sont des moines qui se chargent
de recopier les textes à la main sur des grimoires
C'est fastidieux, surtout quand il s'agit de gros ouvrages.
Alors, pour gagner du temps
et éviter d'avoir trop mal au poignet,
les ecclésiastiques trouvent une parade.
Ils utilisent des abréviations.
Pour certains mots
se terminant par "us" au pluriel.
Ils se servent d'une abréviation latine,
Le "um".
"us" ça fait "um" ?
alors là, il y a un truc qui m'échappe.
"Hiboux", au pluriel, par exemple,
devient "hibo&" écrit de cette manière.
Mais regardez bien.
Ce symbole
que l'on appelle esperluette,
ressemble un peu à un "x".
Cette similitude
va induire les moines en erreur.
Certains vont involontairement
troquer le esperluette
au profit du "x".
Pour une raison inconnue,
La faute ne portera que sur sept mots
nos fameux bijou, caillou, chou, etc
Et c'est ainsi que "hibo&" écrit de
cette manière devient "hibox",
"caillo&", "caillox"
Sauf que pour garder
le son "ou" de "hibou" au singulier,
eh bien on décide finalement
de remettre le "u" entre le "o" et le "x".
Et voilà comment on obtient
le pluriel "hiboux" avec un "x".
Et puis avec le temps.
Eh bien, c'est cette orthographe
qui est entrée dans les dictionnaires.
Bon, les jours de dictée,
il n'y a pas qu'avec les mots
se terminant en
"ou" qu'on s'arrachait les cheveux.
Pneu et bleu, par exemple,
sont
les deux seuls mots se terminant par
"eu"
qui prennent un "s" au pluriel
et non pas un "x".
comme les autres.
Je vais vous faire un aveu.
En sixième, je n'étais pas le premier
en dictée, mais aujourd'hui
ça va beaucoup mieux et j'espère
que pour vous aussi, c'est le cas.
Chouette, c'est la récré !
Non
C'est le signal
que l'on passe à une autre matière.
L'Histoire
Alésia, ce nom vous dit quelque chose ?
Je sais, je sais.
C'est le nom d'une
station de métro à Paris.
C'est surtout le nom d'une grande bataille
qui a opposé les Romains aux Gaulois.
Ah mais oui, nos ancêtres les Gaulois !
Cette histoire débute
en 59 avant Jésus-Christ,
Au passage,
le casque gaulois avec des ailes,
ça n'a jamais existé.
C'est une pure invention.
Cette année-là,
Jules César est élu au poste de consul.
C'est la plus haute charge
de la République romaine
et ce titre lui donne des ailes, à lui.
Il veut mettre le monde à ses pieds
et décide d'envoyer ses légions en Gaule
pour agrandir son empire.
Mais pour y parvenir,
il doit mater les Gaulois.
Ce peuple, que l'on dit fier et courageux,
vit sur d'immenses territoires à cheval
entre ce que sont aujourd'hui
la France et la Belgique.
Mais les Gaulois ont un point faible
les nombreuses tribus passent leur temps
à se faire la guerre.
César comprend très vite
le parti qu'il peut en tirer.
Il parvient sans difficulté à rallier
un certain nombre de clans à sa cause,
tandis que d'autres décident
de faire de la résistance.
Les plus irréductibles
se nomment les Arvernes.
Ils occupent un territoire
qui correspond à l'actuelle Auvergne.
Ils se soulèvent en 54 avant Jésus-Christ
sous l'impulsion d'un guerrier
dont vous n'avez pas pu oublier le nom.
Vercingétorix qui parvient à vaincre
les légions romaines.
Ici, à Gergovie, en 52 avant Jésus-Christ,
César a perdu la bataille,
mais il n'a pas dit son dernier mot.
Les Gaulois sont retranchés
dans un oppidum.
Il s'agit d'une ville fortifiée située
sur une colline dans l'actuelle Bourgogne.
Son nom
Alésia.
César, qui ne renonce jamais, fait
alors parler son génie militaire.
Il assiège la place
en construisant une double ligne
de fortifications, l'une
pour empêcher Vercingétorix de sortir.
L'autre pour empêcher les renforts
d'arriver jusqu'à Alésia.
Les Gaulois, sont pris au piège,
ils n'ont d'autre choix que de se rendre.
Vercingétorix est emprisonné.
Il va croupir durant six ans
dans les geôles romaines
avant de passer l'arme à gauche.
Sans doute exécuté sur ordre de César.
Allez, on va maintenant
faire un tour dans un endroit
où il n'y a vraiment personne.
Enfin, à ma connaissance,
on part dans l'espace.
Ça vous étonne,
si je vous dis qu'en sixième,
j'aimais beaucoup les sciences
et la techno ?
Vous le savez,
le système solaire se compose
d'une étoile, le Soleil, autour
duquel gravitent des planètes.
Huit au total.
Regardez, nous sommes ici
à environ 150 millions
de kilomètres du Soleil
de la planète la plus proche
à la plus éloignée du Soleil.
On trouve donc Mercure, Vénus,
la Terre, Mars,
qui sont des planètes telluriques,
autrement dit
des planètes constituées de roche.
Puis,
Jupiter
Saturne, Uranus et Neptune,
qui sont des planètes gazeuses,
autrement dit, des planètes constituées
de gaz.
Pour les retenir dans l'ordre.
Voici une petite astuce
que notre prof de sixième
nous avait soufflé
et que j'utilise encore.
Il suffit de retenir une phrase :
"Ma vieille tortue Micha joue sur une nappe."
Regardez la première lettre de chaque mot
correspond
à la première lettre de chaque planète.
La plus petite planète du système solaire,
c'est Mercure.
Elle est trois fois plus petite que
la Terre et la plus grosse, c'est Jupiter.
Elle est onze fois plus grosse
que la Terre.
À une époque, on apprenait qu'il
y avait neuf planètes, pas huit.
C'est vrai.
C'est ce que j'ai appris moi aussi.
À mon époque, Pluton était considérée
comme la neuvième planète
du système solaire.
C'est une toute petite planète
dont la surface totale
équivaut approximativement
à la surface de la Russie.
Mais en 2006, l'Union astronomique
internationale a déclassé Pluton.
On a considéré qu'elle ne répondait plus
aux critères officiels
qui définissent une planète.
Pour qu'un astre soit considéré comme une planète,
il doit être plus ou moins sphérique.
C'est bien le cas de Pluton.
Il doit tourner autour du Soleil.
C'est toujours le cas de Pluton.
Il doit avoir nettoyé le voisinage
de son orbite,
autrement dit, les corps célestes
qui se trouvaient dans les parages ont été
aspirés, en quelque sorte, à cause
de la gravité par la planète en question.
Or, il se trouve que Pluton est entourée
de corps célestes
qui font quasiment sa taille
et qui tournent justement sur son orbite.
Pluton n'est donc plus considérée comme
une planète,
mais comme une planète naine.
C'est une catégorie intermédiaire entre planète
et petit corps du système solaire.
Pour une
fois que j'avais la bonne réponse.
Bon, ce déclassement fait encore débat aujourd'hui.
Des scientifiques américains estiment
que Pluton n'aurait jamais dû être exclue.
Il faut dire que c'est
la seule planète qu'ils ont découverte.
Alors, vous le savez,
les planètes ne sont pas les seuls astres
qui peuplent le système solaire.
Il y a aussi leurs satellites.
Certains ressemblent à des planètes
comme deux gouttes d'eau,
mais ils ne tournent pas autour du Soleil.
Toutes les planètes du système solaire
en possèdent, à l'exception de Mercure
et de Vénus.
Jupiter en compte 79,
Saturne 82
et la Terre un seul.
Il s'agit bien sûr de la Lune.
En sixième,
j'y étais souvent dans la Lune.
Moi aussi,
ça m'arrivait de temps en temps.
On passe aux maths,
on va faire un peu de calcul.
416 divisé par 6,
égale 69,3.
Avec un smartphone, ça prend deux secondes.
Quand j'étais en sixième,
on avait déjà des petites calculatrices
à la maison.
Au collège, nous n'avions pas
le droit de nous en servir.
Dommage.
Mais au fait, êtes vous encore capable
de faire une division à la main
comme à l'école ?
On essaie ?
Jamy au tableau !
On commence par tracer
deux traits comme ceci.
Un vertical et l'autre horizontale,
perpendiculaire au premier.
Ensuite, on pose le nombre à diviser.
Ici, à gauche du trait,
on va prendre le nombre 212.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le dividende
et on va le diviser
par 8
au dessus de la barre horizontale.
C'est le diviseur.
On commence par se demander
combien de fois
le premier chiffre du dividende,
à savoir 2, comprend de 8.
Évidemment, c'est impossible puisque 2
est plus petit 8,
2 plus petit que 8 ?
Calé le mec, hein ?
Alors on prend les deux premiers chiffres
du dividende 21.
En 21,
combien y a-t-il de fois 8 ?
3x8 = 24. C'est trop grand.
Deux fois ?
2x8 = 16. Ça fonctionne.
On pose le 2
2x8 = 16
Et là, on fait une petite soustraction
21 -16.
Il reste 5.
Dans 21,
Il y a bien 2x8 + 5.
Ensuite, on descend le 2.
On continue dans 52.
Combien y a-t-il de fois 8 ?
7x8 = 56
C'est trop grand.
6x8 = 48, ça fonctionne.
On fait la soustraction 52 - 48.
Il reste 4
Si on veut un quotient entier.
On s'arrête là et le résultat est 26.
Désolé, mais moi j'obtiens 26,5.
Il s'est planté !
Je n'ai pas terminé.
Ici, il reste 4.
C'est le reste de la division.
Une division avec un reste s'appelle
une division euclidienne
du nom d'Euclide, le grand mathématicien
de la Grèce antique.
Le résultat de la division euclidienne
s'écrit donc alors de la manière suivante.
Mais mon prof ne s'en contentait pas,
il exigeait
le quotient exact de la division.
Allez, encore un petit effort !
Vous êtes d'accord avec moi 212
c'est aussi 212,0.
On peut donc poursuivre la division
en descendant soit zéro.
Mais comme il se trouve après la virgule,
on va également rajouter une virgule
au niveau du quotient en 40.
Combien y a-t-il de fois 8 ?
Là, c'est très simple 8x5 = 40
ôté de 40 = 0.
Le reste est nul.
Et cette fois, ça y est,
la division est terminée.
Le résultat de 212 divisé par 8,
est donc 26,5.
Cette fois, c'est la récré !
Alors ce retour en sixième,
ça a été ?
Pas trop rouillés ?
J'espère que je vous ai rafraîchi
la mémoire et que ça vous a plu.
Si c'est le cas, la prochaine fois,
on passe au programme de cinquième.
Vous savez comment me montrer que vous avez apprécié ce nouveau format ?
À très bientôt.
Les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.